schmidt au dos pour l'invasion des élus
cré in avait à neufchâteau et l'italie
six éléments chacune rapide et à
perdurer la dépendance lagaf' rouge
les
limites
miccoli
et
le grand avantage de l'algérie c'est
qu'il y a twilio donc un gazoduc qui
passe sous la mer et qui peut
approvisionner directement l'italie
[Musique]
c'est le terme aux normes et sa
disparition elle affirma bendaoud
j'écris à brazzaville une importante
déclaration d'intel sur la coopération
entre états les congolais se tord de
l'énergie et de gaz
l'italie et l'afrique ont de longues
relations
coloniales postcoloniale et ce qui fait
que l'italie est connue dans ces pays et
vous avez remarqué que le premier
ministre est accompagné du patron de la
société italienne de pétrole dont l'état
italien détient 30% et donc c'est plus
simple d'aller voir des pays producteurs
avec lesquels on a déjà engagé une
relation de commercial voire même de
confiance dans les années passent et que
ce soit l'égérie que ce soit la libye
[Musique]
le vrai talon d'achille italien c'est
pas tant de trouver du gnl c'est de
savoir comment leurs gazéifiée et à la
différence de la france de l'espagne du
royaume-uni l'italie n'a pas de de
capacités importantes de regazéification
m
les italiens ont des contrats avec les
russes qu'ils sont à des prix très
intéressants donc les italiens sont
prêts à politiquement arrêté faire un
embargo sur ses contrats et à devoir
acheter du gaz plus cher qui viennent
plus loin c'est quand même une position
morale qu'il faut souligner
à
[Musique]